we all made it we're to the end and I
want to thank Jenna and everyone else
for putting this together it has been a
wonderful if exhausting time as the best
conferences always really are I was
supposed to come here to talk about Jon
Huntsman and Mitt Romney oops then Jon
Huntsman dropped out and so we're not
interested in him anymore and instead
then I'm going to discuss the
relationship between Mormonism and the
american progressive movement i'm going
to argue that 20th century Mormonism
intellectual ideals its organizational
culture everything from the lyrics to a
popular children's him that run teach me
all that i must do to live with him
someday from that him to mitt romney's a
leadership style all of this i'm going
to say reflects a fruitful relationship
between 19th century Mormon theology and
the progressive movement of early 20th
century america the phrase we will be
talking about here is eternal
progression a phrase which moved to the
center of the mormon lexicon in this
period this phrase means humanity's
destiny what it is how we attain it the
fact that it is a process of development
and change over time the slow tempering
of the human soul towards divinity
through long effort of a lifetime and
perhaps after now these i just had very
deep roots in Mormon history but the
encounter with progressivism or
vitalized and progressivism offered
mormons new language new concepts new
forms of institutions that Worman still
rely on today i'm now a word about what
progressive means today of course people
to the left of the political center have
adopted the word progressive to replace
the word liberal which George HW Bush
spoke with enough scorn to kill in the
1988 presidential election
to folks at Think Progress or daily
Coast progressivism means a
full-throated endorsement of the
Democratic platform and desire to push
it a little further to the left if you
are disappointed with Barack Obama for
not doing something as opposed to being
annoyed at something he did you're
probably a progressive so it's something
of a shame however that the word has
been so neatly slotted into the dull
polarities of today's American politics
because 100 years ago progressivism
offered a completely different take on
the possibilities of American life for
example listen to Simon patent Simon
patent was one of the founders of
American sociology he was the founder of
the Wharton School of Business he was a
man dedicated to what progressivism in
this period understood about human
nature and human potential when poverty
is gone that to begin with the last
formidable obstacle to the upward
movement of the human race will have
disappeared it is for us to unite all of
our social activities whose motive
forces our charity religion philanthropy
revolt unrest all of these into a
philosophy that is social not sectional
in that it gives to all of them a
reorganized and rational body of
evidence on which to build this is heavy
stuff many Americans and in the 30 or so
years before the first world war broke
out in 1914 shared this rather
extraordinary optimism about the
capacity of human civilization to
improve itself and the most dedicated of
these were the progressives now for a
long time Americans particularly of
angelical Americans believe their nation
to be God's new Israel and destined for
greatness but progressive spanned the
nation's strength in a new place not
necessarily in the favor of God but in
human rationality and science and
self-government they believe that these
things were on their way to making the
United States the most perfect nation in
human history they believed that social
sciences had discerned great truths
about human nature and about how humans
society's worked and that therefore it
is possible given the right amount of
information to put together a consumers
League and tweaked society in precisely
the way you wanted to do it so you can
end poverty and alcoholism and
prostitution educate uplift civilized
everybody absolutely everybody so that
is the first marker of progressivism
confidence and bureaucracy confidence
and science confidence and expertise
there is another as well know and that
is confidence in what human potential
might accomplish given sufficient
education and self-discipline now again
this is an entirely new mini 19th
century evangelicals have done and still
today advocate for a form of Christian
perfectionism attained through piety and
through the Holy Spirit but again what
is interesting is the extent to which
progressives down point these
metaphysical means while still clinging
to this utopian end of perfection they
bound it to the promise of Social
Sciences the possibilities of education
and more than anything else to correct
organization we saw that in Simon
patents exultation about the pword
progress of the race but what's also
look at Jane Addams more than anybody
else was perhaps the icon of American
progressivism she founded whole house a
home for immigrant women and children in
Chicago that offered job training food
shelter opportunities intended to uplift
and civilize the poor she declared that
the impulse towards progressive reform
was quote identical with that necessity
which urges us on towards social and
individual salvation progressivism
teaches that without the advance and
improvement of the whole society no
person can hope for any lasting
improvement in his own moral or
individual condition now like many
progressives Jane Addams wasn't really
conventionally religious but her
language here her language of salvation
indicates the extent to which
progressivism fused technocracy faith in
academia in science and the intellect
with
the Messianic the progressive sought not
only to help the poor but to refine
their souls not merely to educate the
immigrants between still in them virtue
not only to feed people but finally to
make them not perhaps Christian but at
least good so all of this will I hope
help us answer that naughty old question
of why it was the Mormon so readily gave
up on their Zion in the desert their
marital radicalism their economic
communalism and instead immediately made
common cause with that American society
they have just spent several decades
punishing them the Mormons entered the
20th century with tremendous confidence
that the mood of progressivism was
really very well suited to their
religion now let me be clear what I'm
arguing it's a habit for many historians
to discuss this period with words like
accommodation or adaptation language
which implicitly argues that the Mormons
compromise themselves and just some
extent yes perhaps they did but they
also gladly entered into this project
the project of Jane Addams the project
assignment pattern and they did so
because progressivism spoke too many
ideas that Mormons already embraced with
other Antebellum utopians Joseph Smith
had taught of the limitless
possibilities of human potential that
one like many of them he drew that
notion from his belief in the
ontological continuity between God and
man he created an elaborate priestly
hierarchy binding the promise of
salvation to the rituals and
organization of his church and 19th
century Mormon thinkers a particularly
the brothers pract had built rudimentary
connections between science and their
faith so progressive ideals would have
appeal to Mormons because they had this
inheritance but also perhaps because
progressivism offered to replace
something which had been lost and I want
to talk a little bit about what came
before before I speak about what changed
Joseph Smith was never a very systematic
thinker but in the last years of his
life his ideas about religion
in and the societies which religions
could create orbited around the creation
of holy relationships the heaven he
dreamed of was created through the
centralization of human relationships
the sealing of marriages the linking of
ancestors and descendants through proxy
ordinances and of course through the
vaguely dynastic system of polygamous
marriage the leaders of organism which
follow Joseph Smith systematize these
ideas and taught their flock of a heaven
of interlocking kingdoms each centered
upon a righteous man whose glory was
measured by the size of his family the
number of wives and the number of
children this was presumed to be done in
the image of God the literal father of
humankind who sought to exalt his
children as their rise lighten exalt him
and this is all vaguely pre-modern right
it's even medieval in a sense the heaven
predicated on ceremonies rituals the
creation of kinship bonds in the same
way that the King of France might marry
his daughter to the king of England in
order to end a war but the end apolar
can be destroyed this nonetheless
wormans continued to value the idea
central to their religion the literal
likeness between humanity and God the
whole minutes of their relationships
that bound them to him the promise of
humanity's eventual ascendance to
participation in divinity the sacred
structures that the priesthood could
create what I want to do here today then
is talk about some ways in which several
Mormons translated these ideas with the
aid of progressive language they drew
very much on the ideas of early 20th
century social scientists thinkers
reformers and they drew their surgery
ology away from the static dynastic
polygamous afterlife and towards a
language of development of evolution of
the cultivation of character through
participation in the rationalized
institutional structures that replaced
the kin based community the polygamy had
created
the three men that will be spending the
most time with here were all leaders of
the church in the early 20th century
John wit so James Tallmadge bh Roberts
they were all European immigrants they
all were converted as children with
their families Tallmadge in which so
were highly educated they both had phd's
in the sciences Robert cited college
education as well though his education
seems to have been much more that of an
autodidact than anything else they all
serve in the highest leadership of the
church they wrote official manuals of
study and service spokesman for their
faith but more important than the topics
of their education were the habits of
mind that they learned while they were
getting their PhDs their education gave
them a very progressive faith in the
possibilities of human science the
capacities of rationality and their
conviction that scientific language
could be used to express the truths of
their religion and then the application
of scientific principles could advance
the work of redemption which so declared
that quote the only rational philosophy
is based on science now many Protestant
progressives dealt with the challenges
of science I'm to the Bible evolution
things like this and arguing an argued
instead that God's been able to hand
could be seen in the progress of science
we can understand God's salvation by
seeing his hand in the rise of
democratic government in the rise of
education the spread of technology
things like this to these Protestants as
men likes it Harry Emerson Fosdick said
science can clarify an enlightened
Scripture revealed truth should be seen
through its legs Mormons would not
necessarily go that far but they believe
that the language of progressive social
science best expressed what mormonism
taught about the human experience in so
doing then I'm going to argue here that
they give intellectual birth to a
revitalized church organization and
organization targeted at the cultivation
of character through education work and
self-discipline a church shorn of
look at me and instead based on Joseph
Smith's profound optimism about
individual human potential with a few
alterations this achievement remains the
Mormonism largely believed by most
fighter day Saints today their first
task then was the reduction of the
universe to something understandable and
explicable through science liberal
Protestants had done a lot of work to
this end but Mormons had a great deal of
raw material for the effort in the ideas
of Joseph Smith he repudiated the
creation ex nihilo depicting God is a
craftsman rather than as a creator or
per se he insisted the supernatural the
spiritual was merely matter in another
form he moved the divine and the human
on to the same ontological plane to the
progressive theologians then Roberts
would so in tallmadge all of this meant
that God was God because he understood
and manipulated science therefore they
begin to speak about religion in the
language of scientific law James
Talmadge's magnum opus in 1915 biography
Jesus the Christ explained the Christ
suffering and death satisfied apparently
universal laws of Justice which bound
even God's desire to forgive sin should
they not be satisfied which so asserted
that all of human existence was governed
by what he called quote the moderate law
of evolution neither a brute natural
selection nor blind aimless change but
rather geological development towards a
particular directed end what so even
found in this law of evolution God's
plan for his children their course
through earth life to the afterlife and
eventually exaltation as which so said
quote the Mormon plan of salvation is
strictly scientific and it rests upon
the irrevocable laws of the universe the
truth behind Spencer's law of evolution
and the doctrines taught by the Mormon
prophet joseph smith are one and the
same now the Spencer referred to here is
Herbert Spencer a British social
philosopher and a journalist the man who
join the term survival of the fittest
and whose ideas undergirded much of what
progresses believed about the progress
of human civilization Spencer argued
that the social application of Darwin's
ideas meant that all things were both in
ceaseless change but also that all
things were tending towards increased
complexity and increased development for
the progressives this meant that human
civilization and human beings themselves
in fact were tending towards increased
sophistication increased refinement
increased advancement this progress
derived from a process of growth and
change through struggle and conflict and
overcoming of obstacles for Mormons then
especially these three Mormons his
philosophy reconciled their faith and
their world better than anything else
they found which cell wrote that quote
the philosophy of Herbert Spencer is the
oh my philosophy that harmonizes with
our knowledge of today Joseph Smith had
taught that human beings were of the
same type of being that God is but for
these Mormons human that human beings
were literally the children of God an
inference the minions Joseph Smith's
followers had made was of prime
importance they begin to understand them
the process of given ization less in the
dynastic language of polygamy that is
marrying into gods family like you might
marry into a royal family in the Middle
Ages and more through the language of
development and evolution that Spencer
had suggested this manifested in two
ways first his Mormons begin to
emphasize their relationship with God in
terms of biological inheritance not in
terms of rate or status the traits of
divinity were inborn passed along from
parent to child inherited secondly they
didn't describing their cultivation of
these traits in terms of effort we're
finding personal character through
education through overcoming obstacles
through committing to the character
building work that their church was
beginning to offer them they stood
convince them that godhood was every
human beings inheritance provided that
you put in the effort
first relationship in 1916 the first
presidency of the church issued a
proclamation clarifying the relationship
between the Father the Son and humanity
I'm following James Tallmadge they
identified Jehovah the God of the Hebrew
Bible as their pre mortal Jesus Christ
acting is the agent of his father
insisting upon this distinction was
critical according to the First
Presidency because quote Jesus Christ is
not the father of the spirits who have
taken or yet will take bodies on this
earth for he is one of them he is the
son as they are the sons and daughters
of Elohim talmadge applauded what he
called quote the humble offer of Jesus
the firstborn to assume mortality and
two with among men as their exemplar and
their teacher observing the sanctity of
men's agency but teaching them also to
use a right to their divine heritage as
the anomeric said the network of these
relationships here meant that Mormons
closed much Mormons must think as Christ
did it is no robbery to be equal to God
for they can claim the same inheritance
as could he be H robberies wove together
Joseph Smith's argument that human
spirits were the same kind of god and
his inheritors arguments that human
beings were the egg literal children of
God he reconciled these two things and
taught more understanding of human
identity that they except for the most
part today that is human beings are both
uncreated khoa ternal of the same divine
substance as God is but also the literal
children of God given spiritual and then
physical birth through God's creative
powers and therefore capable of
inheriting biologically more than
anything else the same degree of
divinity and glory that their father had
the question then became how to
cultivate this inheritance and here we
come to the notion of effort Roberts
drew on what he called quote Herbert
Spencer's primary doctoring of evolution
to explain how this worked he said the
principle that is evolution is induction
from experience that is Spencer's
theories demonstrated the growth to a
progress came only through living
in the world from dealing with the
trials of life I want to hear turn to a
little example of the way James Talmadge
spoke of the atonement I'm Tallmadge
emphasizes in his biography that quote
the Savior took upon himself the burden
of the sins of mankind in Gethsemane and
even the cross could not exceed the
bitter anguish through which he had
successfully struggled and passed now
Douglas Davies a theologian has argued
that Mormons emphasized Gethsemane more
than the cross because they want to
stress the fact that Jesus chose to
confront this trial that Jesus had to
take this upon himself overcome this and
it is only through overcoming that
freely chosen suffering that true
progress could come wormans has long
cultivated a sort of theology of
suffering a way of talking about
persecution and dilemmas that meant
their character was being refined
through torment in the Progressive Era
this becomes really the way Mormons
cultivate divinity bh roberts perhaps
articulated these ideas most eloquently
when he wrote quote i believe it is
consistent with right reason to say that
some of the lobbyists walks of life the
past which read into the deepest valleys
of sorrow and up the most rugged steeps
of adversity are the very ones which if
a man travels in will best accomplish
the object of his existence in this
world now what did these ideas mean in
practice like many progressives Mormons
came to believe that bureaucratic
organization could foster this sorts of
spiritual reform I said earlier that the
institution of the church comes to
replace the old kingship networks of
polygamy is the ground on which
salvation is worked out and that
salvation increasingly came through
ideas of service of self discipline of
doing work in particular the late
nineteenth and early twentieth century
found Mormons engage in a massive
project directed at the training of
their young people the cultivation of a
Mormon character in their young men and
young woman and warm
woman were really at the forefront of
this effort all of these organizations
sunday-schools a young man's Association
young woman's Association a primary
interpreted the practice of mormon
religion in terms of teaching right
behavior susie young gates Brigham
Young's daughter and a leader in
Mormonism wrote that the young woman
Society of the Salt Lake's 8 ward was
resolved quote in as much as order is
the first law of heaven we will endeavor
to learn the law by making ourselves
acquainted with the principles of life
and salvation we will study all the
literature that would qualify us to
become ornaments in the kingdom of God
that we may merit the approbation of our
brothers our sisters and of God Himself
most influential in this effort was
perhaps ami Brown lineman who is
essentially a Mormon version of Jane
Addams in fact she had met jane addams
at one point while traveling in chicago
and when will she return to utah she
mounted all sorts of efforts here she
became form years and years and years
the director at church social services
she put together efforts in the early
society to aid the poor and to perform
charitable work in Salt Lake City and
she said later in her life that quote no
work could be more important or
satisfying than that of a raising human
life to its highest possible level
through charitable work we see here then
this connection between charitable work
exerting a sort of social effort and the
cultivation of personal character it's
really the hallmark of progressivism all
of these auxiliaries begin to appear in
Mormonism in the late 19th century these
all these ones I've already mentioned
but also a Sunday School of the early
society organization for a woman prayer
groups all of this Joseph F Smith who
was president of the church from 1901 to
1918 made participation in whatever
groups your age and gender made
appropriate an expectation if you were
to be considered a practice of
latter-day Saint and this happened from
the first time these things had largely
been voluntary before then now
participation in these vast arrays of
auxiliaries that Mormons
today became an expectation something
Mormons were supposed to do by the early
mid 20th century then to be a Mormon
increasingly came to mean meeting a
standard of personal behavior achieved
primarily through participation in the
institution of the church and Mormonism
still retains this profound devotion to
its institution by the time of the Great
Depression Mormons had erected the
church welfare program system of aid to
the needy which encouraged recipients to
offer a labor and to cultivate habits of
thrift and industry in return for any
benefits but the argument perhaps is
best reflected in the massive project of
the mid 20th century that is called
co-relation this systematic
reorganization reaggravated of lines of
church Authority which brought along
zileri is under the supervision of
members of the quorum of the Twelve
Apostles which establish a regular and
uniform curriculum and which oversees
Church publications for orthodoxy one
church leader argued that the process of
coalition was not simply organizational
that it was not merely intended to help
the church's bureaucracy run better
rather he said this is a necessary tool
in God's plan for saving souls the
education that is administered through
coal related materials is notoriously
oversimplified many Mormons complain
about this but it is targeted less and
increasing knowledge than it is upon
encouraging warrants to become better
and more dutiful people the lesson on
the Sabbath day in the current slide
disco manual for instance dwells very
briefly on the origins of the Sabbath or
the theology of the Sabbath and instead
devote some devotes most of its time to
questions about how faithful Saints can
better observe the Sabbath in their own
lives this is education as moral
improvement more or less now while his
political career was still blooming to
Massachusetts Mitt Romney declared
himself a progressive a clip that will
surely come back to haunt him but he was
more right than he knew Mormons still
retained a sort of unadulterated
confidence and organization that many
Americans left in the trenches of the
world
wars are in the Food lines of the Great
Depression though the vast majority of
Mormons identify its conservative or
Republican they speak with justified
pride about their churches welfare
program about the vast and capable
church bureaucracy that makes Mormonism
an identical experience in provo or
Paraguay or Poland their faith
simultaneous dedication to business like
efficiency and the refinement of souls
is something that can seem dissonant at
a time but really can be traced I think
to this period Romney is a technocrat
but he is also a technocratic convinced
that technocracy can make people better
this peculiar fusion of ideas that have
long since been severed in American
politics than the Morgans oddly enough
are the ones you still keep alive thank
you thank you Matt and all the panelists
is Joe run to with the microphone I
guess not so please use the microphone
to ask questions and we'll have a lively
discussion I'm sure
Emily's the switch
upon the poles from Obama ok so we're
two weeks Romney's nominee with two
weeks up from the general election
November the Democrats tried everything
my system I suspect and I predict
they're going to throw the Mormon bomb a
week or two before what's the Mormon
bomb it's going to be something to do
with the church and it's going to be
spread out among the public and it's not
going to look good and then you have to
ask will Harry Reid sit back quietly and
let the church bomb explode or is he
going to come and defend them my guess
is he'll probably be quiet about it you
can comment if you like it won't be a
bomb it won't come two weeks before the
election it will be subtle it will be
quiet it will be constant from the
beginnings of the general election there
can't possibly be amongst those
activists and those people most close to
and most committed to obama's reelection
there can't possibly be an absence of
people pondering how best can we use the
unfamiliarity the strangeness the
outside earnest of Mormonism to peel
away likely supporters of you know Mitt
Romney as a candidate I strongly suspect
that if any of these people are
contemplating you know what you suggest
you know some sort of bombs some sort of
you know scandalous attack on some you
know outrageous theological element of
the Mormon faith that it would go down
terribly but what wouldn't necessarily
go down terribly are subtle ways of
communicating the the difference and the
oddity and the out-of-place pneus of
Mitt Romney and do so in such a way as
to target people who probably would have
ended up voting for Romney but are not
deeply committed the people that are
deeply committed conservative
Republicans and so forth they're going
to vote for him to get rid of President
Obama remote no matter what but people
on the bubble especially evangelicals
moderate evangelicals on the bubble that
sort of subtle messaging would work I
really doubt that any smart people are
thinking all we need to do is wait and
then expose the temple ceremony and
it'll make a difference no I think that
would go down terribly but the other
stuff the more subtle stuff I can't
believe that there are people that
aren't thinking about that right now
that's my answer Karen I was wondering
to what extent these progressive Mormon
leaders at like progressive Jewish or
Protestant leaders participated in
eugenics work and during the 20th
century seems to be sort of the elephant
in the room when you're talking about
for graduate scientific thinking and
that didn't come into the into your top
so I was wondering if you found that um
yeah you know and that is these
progresses are very charming in a lot of
ways or kind of unfettered optimism and
their navet is very termini there's
also this element of social control in
progressivism this until we can just
make people do better things and we can
make people be better and you know when
you don't see a lot of eugenics in is
really more amazing but you do see a lot
of talk as polygamy is coming to a close
about how pull again
is making Mormonism something of
ethnicity and how George q cannon speaks
about how polygamy is making Mormons it
better race that it is breeding
faithfulness into their bones so that
maybe the version with in Mormonism that
that you don't see or that you see
elsewhere and more scientific and
technical attic for answers 22 comments
a brief one as to the whole progressive
thing I actually see that leeching into
my own person poverty to a large extent
my friends call me a fan Jellicle
elitist because I'm gonna lead us but I
want everybody else to be one too um as
far as the the language barrier I
noticed that when i speak with a lot of
my non mormon friends there is an
obvious language barrier in trying to
communicate what mormon congregations
mormon wards really are and what mormon
worship is really like and I kind of
wonder how much the churches you know we
offer this Christianity plus kind of
explanation how much of that plays into
their media's representation on this
Protestant prism that you're talking
about the church's Christianity plus
well you know it's like um we have the
Virgin Mary and the angel Moroni you
know we have with Christianity but we
have more of it you know this kind of
way that I think the church is kind of
talked about it has played into that a
little bit and I just wonder how much
that that really plays into that or if
this is something that's completely from
the outside how to answer that I think
the church has done better to try to
build bridges verbal vocabulary bridges
try to use terms that make more sense
the church public relations people are
all over trying to explain Mormonism but
the examples I gave you are comfy
the current so I don't see a lot of
improvement in that I still think
there's it's such a foreign world for
most journalists to go and not there are
many of them actually go to a Mormon
ward or go to a service or something and
if they do they have really no idea
what's going on there there's there's
not a good analog for it elsewhere and
so I mean I'd say the best thing is is
of these bridge-building scholars who
can speak both languages or members who
can speak both languages can say oh in
our experience we call it this because
there are common experiences it's just
that we call them they call them
different things I don't know if that
answers your question night I think it's
getting a little better maybe I have an
observation about that just the the tone
of the quality of religion coverage
generally when I first started here in
1985 I started getting calls from
reporters and typically I have to spend
the first one 15-20 minutes briefing the
reporter about what to ask me or for his
or her story and then in part because of
the rise of the religious right in the
1990s there was this real emphasis on
having reporters covering religion with
some knowledge of religion and I mean
here at Columbia we have a joint program
with the journalism school and the
religion department for example and for
a while as you know Peggy there was a
sort of Golden Age of religion reported
the Dallas Morning News had huge
coverage and so forth and other papers
as well what's happened unfortunately
over the last decade is with the
recession is that these are the first
people to leave to get to lose our job I
my my electronic address book is full of
names of people who were regulars and
who have just lost their jobs I mean
neelam Banerjee just name a few names of
you know Gus neighbor now Syracuse and
it's real it's unfortunately I think
that's AI that's exactly my experience
as well the political reporters who call
me are relatively unfamiliar with even I
mean yet I would say they even don't
know the prospect you know surely I mean
they don't know Mormons but or even
Protestants and so it's all orange world
to them and that makes the coverage of
Mitt Romney really problematic I think
um the scholar of religion Jonathan
Smith is argued that the Academy suffers
from a protestant bias and by what he
means by that is the liberal Protestants
who became the earliest academics who
studied a religion where people who had
generally come to the conclusion that
the best form of religion is personal
and spiritual and it's about ethics and
about doing nice things and so any form
of religion that added on to that was
seen as creating useless accretions and
strange rituals and stuff that was
backwards and retrograde and actually
interfered with living a good and
ethical life and I think this has in the
20th century become sort of what
Americans have expected about religion
in general the religion is useful in so
far as it teaches people to do nice
things but rituals and strange underwear
and stuff like that are all weird and
necessarily for and the Plus that you're
talking about
hi my name is Matthew Teeter and I'm
more on a Mormon I'm from upstate New
York and as I grew up my best friends
were always evangelicals are Jews and
then I moved out to town got the culture
shock of being with other mormons and I
I was I found it fascinating I seeing
the evolution of the approach to Mitt
Romney and the concern and I think a lot
of the concern about what his you know
his presidency would be comes from
ignorance but then at the same time my
best friend actually who is an
evangelical Christian he he said you
know I know your religion very well he
does because when I went on my mission
he actually started investigating the
church and wanted to know more then
decided not to join and he knows we have
long conversations and the issue of
theology I don't I think is a little
nebulous because that's a very broad
stroke and I he says it's the doesn't
use this word but it's the epistemology
that concerns him about how Mormons
approach decision-making we we don't
discredit rationals and we collect you
know we believe in a scientific method
but ultimately we do take our decisions
very important decisions to God and we
ask you know for help in that and a lot
of times it comes to come through
confirmation but at the same time
sometimes something it would get receive
an answer that doesn't jive with what
we've researched and we will still go
with that decision because it's what we
believe God wants us to do and he says
like you know he comes up with some
extreme hypothetical but ultimately you
know it's like if you are believing
Mormon that is what you will do you know
if you are a good Mormon here to your
theology or epistemological theology so
I'm I just wondering if you could speak
to that you know if if somebody
distilled it to that core concern you
know what what would the appropriate
response be what would your response be
um I say that your friend is very
observant I was actually having
lunch with Damon linker yesterday and I
was kind of laying out for him in a in a
confused sort of way the thesis of my
argument about you know this this drive
that we have within the church to
experience this knowingness this this
this confirmation the fact that you know
were we're taking from these experiences
from our encounter with the Book of
Mormon from our dealings with trials you
know some sort of truth that we can know
and he said well the real
distinctiveness you know civilly
speaking about the Mormon Church isn't
really their theology it's their
epistemology minutes that's the word
that that he used I I do think that that
broadly speaking it's important for
members of the church as we interact
more and more with not just non-members
but start interacting on on a different
level through many different venues than
we have before you know to recognize
that our recourse to this kind of
collectively experienced confirmation
this experience of truth this this sort
of decision making as you talk about it
that ends with you know a personal
knowledge a personal revelation I mean
it's it's it's a very very powerful
spiritual experience and it it's not a
unique characteristic of our church I
mean you know the Society of the front
of his friends the Quakers for a long
time really embraced a similar sort of
collective experience of the truth and
and some versions of Quakers and still
strongly emphasized it but amongst
a lot of the rest of the kind of
dominant voices and our kind of quasi
establishment or non-establishment
establishment the civil religion of the
United States being more amenable to you
know a discourse that doesn't end with
the testimony is I think more common and
I think that you know we will have to
adapt and maybe the religious Main
Street in the United States will have to
adapt to to our differences that way the
way we really emphasize epistemology the
way we really emphasize knowingness in
perhaps a different way and probably
also to a different degree than most
other Christian churches in modern
liberal America do Caleb hi my name is
Caleb Maskull I'm a grad student at
Princeton if i may just a tiny comment
on the epistemology question it seems
like there's a lot of similarity between
mormon epistemology and say Pentecostal
epistemology which is becoming so vastly
mainstream that maybe it's the liberals
who are going to have to reconsider
something did but just that's not my
question a question for man but but I
would suggest that that if there was
somebody you know coming from of
strongly Pentecostal background I mean a
strongly Pentecostal background who is
making a serious run for a presidential
nomination they would be experiencing
much of the same sort of outside earnest
and that sound that sounds right to me I
was thinking more on the sort of general
religious plain that the epistemology of
testimony
rounding spiritual knowledge is on the
you know certainly I in the global
majority but politically that's yet
you're right but my questions for
Matthew I'm thinking about the
narratives that inform the the
transition that you're talking about
sort of a particular question then maybe
you could just comment are you saying
that the transition to progressivism it
like our Mormons the perfect American
progressives in the sense that it has to
be the kingdom of God in America and is
that why you think that Mormon
progressivism has been sustained through
the kind of typical story of disillusion
I think well you know and putting down
this great woolly beast it is
progressivism is a very difficult thing
there have been books and books and
books written about it but I think
Mormons adopt a lot of progressive
language of progressive ideas but they
are to a large degree too religious for
many of the other progressives for
people like atoms or Simon patent came
from Protestant backgrounds and
Calvinists backgrounds but were not
explicitly religious the Mormons take
all this notion and turn it to kind of
this fantastical religious and
soteriological end so they're not
perhaps the ideal progressives that many
other progressives would have selected
is that good which does well maybe what
I would just say then is are they that
the strongest the most resilient strain
of progressive because of the way
progressivism and Americanism are wet so
when you hit World War one a lot and
subsequent years a lot of people give up
on progressivism because they give up on
a certain vision of American pneus is it
the case yeah that you think Mormons are
so absolute laund to a vision of what
American must be um you're emphasizing
them I think the American pneus I
but i would say that a lot of the ideas
and ideals that you are probably
implicit in that word for you are very
much there last question okay how people
do to it that's okay but I have two
questions um the one is a comment and
and the other is the question the
comment is that of course in Mormon this
is sort of mostly directed at Matt in in
the Mormon Church in the 20th century we
you definitely had that very strong
progressive influence Roberts Talmadge
wit so school but in the Mormon Church
that it may be deep in the practice but
on an ideological level it was shoved
aside by another strain of monism the
feelings mrs. Joseph field leads to note
that I don't actually think that's
necessarily correct but you can you can
complete okay well I my question or my
observation is that that seems to
parallel what was happening the larger
society where the old social gospel
liberal Protestant progressives have
been pushed aside by the rise of
evangelical Christianity that that's
more of an observation that this is the
the question suppose that Willard Mitt
Romney is elected president of the
United States how will we deal with the
inevitable tendency of that will follow
of the news media the populace the world
to we begin to equate Mormonism with a
president Romney's policies and start to
hold mormons individual Mormons in the
church accountable for policies that
people disagree with or mistakes or
failures that he makes I can sort of
read it right okay I can address the
first issue um
I think the key is in your phrase the
practice right because I think assuredly
actually Joseph fielding Smith and
McConkey and these other conservative
theologians still hold very very much to
this ideologies ecology of effort and
ideology of dedication to church
organization it really very much
characterizes what would so in Robertson
all the rest had set up there more
biblical and more scripture 'used in
their theology than the progressives
were and one reason why progressivism
could enter Mormonism was because men
like wood so we're interested in outside
scholarship and in work and ideas and
philosophy from outside the church
fielding smith and McConkey are not they
spurn all of that they say we're going
to turn to the scriptures and the
scriptures alone but by then this
intense dedication to the proposition
that human beings can make themselves
perfect this near pelagianism is very
very deeply embedded in McConkey and in
Joseph fielding Smith as well so that is
what I would say to your first point us
to the second actually I don't know that
I have much so one of you guys want to
take a shot at it I think Ken Jennings
already wrote about this which is it's
dangerous for Mormons most visible
figure to be a politician because
inevitably Mormons will like and not
like things he does and everyone else
will like and not like things and the
almost complete you know identifying him
as a Mormon I you know ken just said yay
I hope it doesn't win you know for that
reason I don't know if obviously a lot
of mormons are cheering for him to win
but i think it is problematic for the
church i gotta say but there is a
there's a possible kind of silver lining
to that or i don't know if it's a
negative or positive thing but there's
another side to it some of us were
talking about some of these very issues
last night and dave campbell over here
made the comment and i think he's
absolutely right that if mitt romney
wins the presidency
you will see the church leadership doing
everything in their power to distance
themselves from any perception of
connection between the church and the
decisions that he makes they will not be
able to succeed at that entire obviously
people will think what they will think
but they will really try to do that and
I think he's right I think that you know
one possible consequence of a mitt
romney presidency is an even more
politically sensitive church leadership
because they will be concerned about
perceptive backlashes otherwise there
would be no prop 8 under a president
Romney just something I'm trying to wrap
my head around it seems like one of the
most interesting dynamics about this
full conference in this moron moment
there's this push for mainstreaming I
think and I think a lot of and I guess
what I'm talking about there's this
contrast between Mormons and Herod
desire to be mainstream but also our
love of being peculiar you know so we we
both are hesitant when Mitt Romney cos
question about his faith because we
don't want him judged by that but we
also love the fact that everyone's
talking about us you know most Mormons
won't go to see the book more musical
but we love the fact that there is what
you know so I guess my question is how
does that play out going forward and
especially in kind of a post Mormon
moment so say mit romney does won the
presidency and the micro you know the
looking glass is turned elsewhere and
how do we deal with suddenly we don't
get as much attention as maybe we'd like
and how that done
myself I'd be really happy to get
Mormons out of the limelight but that's
really selfish time will go on you know
people will you know grow up they'll you
know they'll be kids they'll be
teenagers they'll be young adults and
there'll be a Mormon president and then
they'll encounter Mormons in their life
you know their co work will be a Mormon
their college roommate will be a Mormon
they'll date a Mormon and they'll say oh
yeah yeah Romney you know there will be
this adaptation and the adaptation will
be on both sides it'll be in America's
kind of civil religion in the way
Mormons are treated but it'll be within
the mormon church itself I mean it
happened to Catholicism you know we
still have this Protestant lens but they
eventually made room you know for the
people who go to Mass though the mass
changed presumably eventually they will
make room for people to go to testimony
meetings though probably that will
change also okay I think we need to to I
have the several people i want to thank
before we conclude in just a minute here
first of all our participants on the
panel and all of the participants in the
conference thank you so much
again want to thank Emily and Chelsea in
particular and the Institute for
religion and culture of public life
actually the head of the Institute Mark
Taylor is here and mark is probably
responsible than anyone else for this
conference because he kept overcoming my
resistance to this idea and eventually
he prevailed and that's why we have this
conference so thank you Mark and finally
to my co-organizer Jana Reese thank you
so much